each week american history tv sits in on
a lecture with one of the nation's
college professors you can watch the
classes here every saturday at 8 pm and
midnight eastern and sundays at
1pm during world war ii
the u.s government detained more than
400 000 nazi prisoners of war in camps
all across america next texas a m
university professor arnold cramer
discusses how the u.s was able to detain
such a large number of pows by
converting horse racing tracks high
school gyms and military bases into pow
camps professor kramer also details the
humane treatment of german pows as
prescribed by the 1929 geneva convention
with the hope of securing similar
treatment of american pows in germany
texas a m university is in college
station this class is 90 minutes
all right
today we're going to talk about
one facet of the second world war
something that uh very few people uh
ever consider actually
uh the uh when the war broke out in 1941
in december of 1941
uh we were
we had to rush to
start building up the army
we had to uh
get the factories cranked up we had to
start producing weapons we had to start
producing planes we had to start
producing
consumer goods
people were moving from the south to the
north for jobs people were moving from
the midwest to the to the west coast for
the airline
industry and the whole country was
moving
one of the last things that anybody
would have thought about
was
prisoners of war what do we do if we
capture prisoners of war it's somehow
never never concerned us
[Music]
they were pouring in quickly by the
hundreds
and by the thousands
in the
end
we are going to have
uh nearly 400 000 german prisoners of
war in the united states and we had no
plans at all uh
how to do anything with them
they
first went to britain because britain
had been in the war since september of
1939 but by this time britain was full
so now they're being shipped to the
united states
prisoners poured in
as i'll show you in a moment
to
anything we had available
we set up tent cities we used
gymnasiums in local high schools
santa anita racetrack was turned into a
prisoner of war camp
there were
virtually no precedents we had nothing
to work with
there is a
a wonderful book by a professor named
robert doyle at franciscan university in
steubenville ohio
who talks about
uh the prisoners that the united states
had held in the past but otherwise we
had no precedence at all
we're working blind let me show you how
it
how it looked at the time
here are
german prisoners
being
searched here they are after a battle in
north africa look how many prisoners we
took
if you see this uh program as
as capturing 5 or 10 or 20 we're
capturing german prisoners by the
thousands now they're capturing our
prisoners as well
we found that among the german prisoners
were mongolians on occasion where
koreans on occasion somehow they had
somehow become swept into the german
army and
what are we going to do with them we
don't know what to do with the germans
we have very few translators available
anybody who spoke german was generally
sent overseas to deal with the germans
in the front lines we had nobody at home
or very few people who spoke german
certainly not mongolian certainly not
korean
and yet we have to deal with them as
well
this is a standard camp in north africa
this is a camp at oran
north africa
it may look like your classes from time
to time but in fact this is a
standard camp
of german prisoners of war now what are
we going to do with them
washington
went back over the rules of war the
rules of war there are rules of war
believe it or not the geneva convention
of 1929
indicates what we should and shouldn't
do
and they looked into the geneva
convention
and it said that that prisoners should
be taken to the same climate where they
were captured
the ideas
to protect us as well if you're captured
in the tropics
to send you to alaska or places like
that is uh is unhealthy
so the same climate where they were
captured they were captured in tunisia
north africa
and they determined that the closest
climate to north africa was
texas
and they started shipping them here to
texas
this is a ship full of german prisoners
headed our way
these were called liberty ships that is
the um
ships that brought ammunition and and uh
replacement troops uh and so on to the
front lines instead of going back empty
are now going back filled with
german prisoners
but where do we put them
here they are coming into the united
states generally at camp shanks
new york
and now what do we do with them
they're coming in by the
by the hundreds and by the thousands
here they are being searched once again
here they are being given a blast of ddt
to kill any lice or fleas or things like
that that they might have brought in
with them
now we had them fill out forms and the
key to the program is starting to come
clear that is we are going to live by
the geneva convention
whatever the geneva convention requires
which it does
it requires that
prisoners
fill out forms and send those to their
families so their families know that
they're safe and in american hands
the key is going to be the geneva
convention
it is our logic
that if we take good care of the german
prisoners here
that hopefully they'll take good care of
our our prisoners there
we are going to have an average of 370
000 german prisoners in the united
states about 70 000 of whom were in
texas
the germans were holding 90 000
americans in their hands
and we hope that if we treat them well
here that they will treat our prisoners
well there it didn't quite work out that
way
but we are decent people and we probably
would have done the right thing anyway
the
german prisoners
are now put on trains
pullman trains as a matter of fact very
fancy trains
and we start shipping them to american
bases
around the country that have some extra
room
for example i checked to find
that places like camp forest tennessee
camp clark
missouri camp blizz texas bragg north
carolina devon's massachusetts
and so on shelby mississippi
fort st
sill oklahoma and so on if they had any
room there we put part of that
regular army base aside and we put the
prisoners there
they are quickly going to over
overrun those camps we need more room
we are looking for places to put the
camps generally in the south and
southwest
in the united states and the reasons are
one
the south and southwest has more land
than the north
second there are very few war industries
in the south and southwest
third there's the problem of insulation
during winter and things like that if we
had the camps up north
so that we
generally look to put new camps
in the south and southwest
until we develop those camps we set up
tent cities here's a tent city in
huntsville
here is a high school uh gymnasium
we turned into a prison camp you can see
the hoop on the side
uh these are prison camps for for uh
camps for german prisoners and we still
don't know what to do with them
this becomes our standard camp
now we're building
uh regular camps
these uh little squares in the center
are barracks each set of each barracks
held about 150 men with a potbelly stove
in the center and so on
uh each set of barracks is surrounded by
barbed wire becomes a compound so we
have on this picture one two three
compounds
and then you have dozens of other
buildings
you've got canteens you've got
gymnasiums you've got
uh places for uh handicrafts you've got
mess halls you've got hospitals and
clinics this becomes a major city
this is a standard camp in the united
states
and this is where they were generally
located
these camps are the largest camps in the
country generally with 3 000 men or more
we had camps that went down as
small as
120
sometimes even less 75
men working in some
factory
but most of the bigger camps had 3 000
or more
and this is where they were located
3 000 men or more
if there's anything you should know
about this at this point it is that the
first level of prisoners coming in
we're from the africa core
so the africa corps
the tuffys coming in are the ones who
are going to set the rules for the next
groups coming in after them
the africa corps were the tuffys
if there's anything else you should know
about the
camps
they were
generally
about 150 miles from the coast we don't
want to get them too close to the coast
and
again it's the geneva convention that
dictates everything
these camps have to be exactly the same
as our own soldiers
many times and there there are stories
about this
that uh american guards had to sleep in
tents
while the german prisoners slept in
tents even though there were places for
the for the american guards to sleep
they couldn't sleep in their buildings
until the germans had their buildings
finished
the uh
special camps uh
no let me put another way
there were uh
for very high ranking uh members of the
uh german army and we captured
uh exactly 40 german generals and three
german admirals now what do we do with
them
we sent them to a special camp in
clinton mississippi
not far from jackson mississippi and
sadly we left them there
we didn't do anything with them here we
have a wonderful opportunity to
use them for propaganda to
get them to talk to the other troops or
to do something with them and we didn't
do anything with them
here they sat
40 generals and three admirals
sitting in camp clinton mississippi for
the entire
duration of the war and we didn't do
anything uh
uh with them it was foolish the british
were already using their their
high-ranking uh prisoners
for propaganda for information and we
didn't uh
we didn't do anything about it
the the
prisoners are responsible for
taking care of their own camp
enlisted prisoners always had to work
officers don't have to work that's the
way the world goes
and they have to take care of their own
camps which means we're putting them to
work we're putting them to work
taking care of the maintenance of the
camp
taking care of the uh
building the roads in the camp gravel
roads and
so on
this is a
an average
picture of a german prison camp on the
inside
the barracks
um
this was in camp shelby mississippi i
don't know why they have a trench for
for a water there's probably no water
there
of all the camps let me mention to you
the largest camp in the country
was at hearn
16 miles from this spot little hearn
texas had the largest of prison camp in
the country
5
100
uh prisoners of war
almost entirely africa core
in a town
hearn itself only had
about 2
300 inhabitants
and outside of town they had
5 100 german prisoners
the the
we wanted to put them to work
we wanted to keep them tired
uh once they checked in they got their
id cards like this
in those years
they set up shop
and like soldiers everywhere they took
out their pinups and pictures of the fam
and
and they moved in
they didn't know how long the war was
going to last
they were settled in
and we wanted to keep them tired the
whole idea was keep them preoccupied and
keep them tired the germans loved sports
and we intended to
encourage them to play soccer or any
other sport just keep them tired tired
and distracted prisoners don't think
about escaping
so we had
almost daily in almost every camp there
were daily soccer matches on sunday
afternoon there were major
championship matches
in some camps you could pull up
alongside
you and i
and we could make bets with the guards
about which side was going to win
the idea was keep them tired
we wanted to introduce them to
democracy
after all
most of these
fellows had grown up in nazi germany
and knew very little about democracy
while we've got them here
let's
introduce them to democracy
and the best way we thought to do that
was
to allow them to encourage them to have
a camp newspaper
every camp had its own newspaper
we gave the mimeograph machines in those
years and lots of paper
and
make a a
a newspaper
and these newspapers by the way were
quite sophisticated
they had very sophisticated articles
about the how the war was going about
german history
um
they had in the back a uh classified
column i want to trade so much for this
i'll trade these three of these for two
of those and so on now
there is an ulterior motive and i have
to tell you that too
the ulterior motive is we wanted to find
out what they were up to the best way to
find out what they were up to was
for us to continue following their
newspaper
if for instance
in the classifieds somebody wanted to
trade something for tools or for wire
cutters or for a saw
or something like that there may be
something afoot that we meet we need to
keep an eye on
um
we could tell how political they were
getting
by watching the articles
every april 20th was hitler's birthday
and if the article suddenly praised
hitler to a a
very high extent we knew that there's
still something going on in those camps
we uh this is a camp bastrop 56 miles
from this spot
uh
the prisoners you see wore a
dark blue uh work clothes with the
letters pw stenciled in yellow front and
back prisoner of war
if there's anything that you should
notice here and that's why i show this
to you
is that the bread they're they're eating
is uh german black bread
round black bread they didn't like our
bread that wonder bread that uh you know
white bread it's nutritionally bankrupt
anyway and they uh they were just they
didn't like it at all
what do you like we want german bread
fine
we're going to give you any kind of
bread that you want
just remember to keep writing your
families and telling them how well
you're being treated hopefully it's
going to tr you'll be able to treat our
prisoners well as
as well
plus if you like the food you'll throw
away less
and it was very important during the war
to eat everything on your plate
so if you're eating something that you
like
you will throw away less
this isn't done just for the german
prisoners we also had about 52 000
italian prisoners in the united states
and we had exactly 5 000 japanese
prisoners
not the nisai japanese who were rounded
up on the west coast but military
japanese
captured in the pacific
and they were
shipped to uh
clarinda iowa and to camp mccoy
wisconsin
and there they spent the war years my
point in bringing that up is
that uh now we fed the italians more
pasta if that's what you want
we'll give you as much pasta as you like
just keep telling your families how well
you're being treated
uh the japanese wanted more pork and
more noodles that's fine we'll give it
to you just keep telling your family my
point again is the geneva convention is
what's dictating our
behavior we will encourage them to uh
uh to learn
handicrafts
uh this took place at camp shelby
mississippi
you want to learn something else if it's
going to occupy your time
terrific we can do it
handicrafts no problem we'll put you
into a handicraft shop
this
is also at camp shelby
libraries we established a library in
every prison camp
some of the libraries were large enough
to do justice to a small high school
they were
allowed to read books that they couldn't
have read in germany at the time
anti-nazi books and things like that
the whole idea is if we're going to take
nazism away from you we want to
substitute something else
music
many of these german prisoners had been
musicians before the war
and um
they were given instruments if they
wanted them and they set up orchestras
this is from mahea texas
camp mahaya and at camp mejia they had
three orchestras
this is just one of the orchestras
they put on plays
they put on
musicals
some of them quite sophisticated
this was at camp trinidad colorado
the gentleman and these are all men of
course
uh the gentleman in the front
um
his name is rudiger von vegemar i
interviewed him
rudiger from vachmar roger
a very
aristocratic family blue-blooded
rudiger von vegemar
and after the war was over he went back
to germany as they all had to
and he began to work his way up the
system
and
in the end he went on to become the
president of the general assembly of the
united nations
now did this work out for us he loved
america he spoke
english fairly well
[Music]
and he became the president of the
general assembly of the united nations
would he pay money for this photograph
today
uh here is another uh musical
the
musical is usually brought in between
500 and 700 men
the commandant of the camp and his wife
the american commandant his wife people
came in from the from the uh community
and
these were very sophisticated
shows
here is a professor a physics professor
before the war
now he's a prisoner of war
and he set up his experiments and just
continued
just as he had before he was a soldier
now comes another issue and that is a
question of work
until now we had prisoners working in
their own camps
whether it was a section of an american
camp or it was their own camp
they were responsible for
everything that needed to be done
they were responsible for maintenance
for the roads for anything in the camps
in
mid-1943
the united states was labor starved
we were bringing in laborers from mexico
laborers from haiti
all of our boys were overseas fighting
who was bringing in the crops
and it
occurred to the
war department that here we have
nearly 400 000 german prisoners in our
midst
why don't we put them to work
the geneva convention says that that's
all right as long as they're doing work
that's not related to the war effort
they cannot do things that are related
to helping
uh defeat their own country
so um
farmers
and factory owners were invited to ask
for
german prisoners
and
if you go to almost any rural area
and ask almost any farm family do you
remember german prisoners during the
second world war oh sure sure
they they helped bring in the crops over
here they they
they were used all over
what you did was you filled out a form
like this
you sent it to the local prison camp and
you said i need 15 german prisoners
you promised to
pay them
80 cents a day
which was in those years a lot of money
and the uh and you had to promise them a
bologna sandwich
and they would uh two days later there'd
be a truck full of german prisoners
dropped off at your farm
together with an american guard the
american guard usually handed his rifle
to one of the german prisoners
uh and went to sleep under the truck and
the german prisoner walked around with
an empty rifle there were no bullets in
it walked around
guarding the others
and the prisoners had a wonderful time
many of them were farm boys to begin
with here they have the opportunity to
drive tractors
the farm families often took them in for
lunch
they had a wonderful time
working on the
on the farms
they brought in the
citrus fruit
in the valley
they they ch they cut
lumber this is in pollock texas
they repaired uniforms
you can see the signs are in german
they repaired uniforms
they brought in the crops
and
they
[Music]
cut sugar cane in florida they they uh
harvested
potatoes in maine they
they brought in the crops 1943 44 and
part of 1945
the crops that were brought in were
brought in by german prisoners of war
you couldn't drive 50 miles in those
years without bumping into a team of
german
prisoners pw
uh cutting planting picking something up
here they are in a uh an olive factory i
didn't know that we had olive factories
but uh the olive stuffing factories
this in danbury
we paid them in coupons
now here's a curious thing
these are from camp rucker alabama
we paid them in instead of paying them
in cash 80 cents a day we paid them in
coupons why would we pay them in coupons
and not in cash what would you think
come on tell me
well it's certainly true that they used
those camp cat those canteens in the
camp they couldn't
take them anyplace else tell me
if they escaped they didn't want them
using the
transporters
that's exactly right
what they didn't want to do was put a
lot of cash in the prisoners hands they
might be able to combine the money among
themselves they could bribe a guard
perhaps
they would be able to buy a train ticket
or a bus ticket
this was um
the safest way was to pay them in
canteen coupons
if you had yes after the war could they
exchange it for real cash
if you didn't spend all the money all
the canteen coupons that you received
the government maintained a
an account for you
here mr alfred klein
has already saved up
14.80 which may sound like nothing to
you and i today but 14 in those years
don't forget
we're just coming out of the depression
14
is a lot of money many of these
prisoners went back with
hundreds of dollars
i've interviewed german prisoners
i interviewed
one german prisoner who bought his farm
back from the bank when he got back to
germany
with the money that he had saved up as a
german prisoner here he bought his farm
back from the from the bank had been
foreclosed during the depression
and they got certificates
this is very important to
to uh europeans especially germans
especially
certificates
uh here is uh werner richter uh who
became a uh
uh
was a worker
and uh
did very well satisfactory satisfactory
satisfactory these became invaluable
when they went back to germany they
could get a job much more easily than
anyone else saying look i worked for you
folks i did a good job for you folks
and they were often given jobs before
anybody
else here is a uh
a picture of a canteen
you went in
this happens to be a uh
an officer a ranking officer but you
could buy almost anything you wanted in
the canteen
here they are
discovering miller high life beer
let me tell you
this is a camp evelyn michigan
here they are discovering coca-cola
and this is
in aliceville alabama
you can tell that uh
this fellow in the center is from the
africa corps with an extended bill on
his hat
and these are the things that you could
buy with your canteen coupons
the same things that any american
soldier could buy
it's not really
easily read
but almost anything at all sewing kits
lacquer glue games lighter fluid
fill anything you want
just keep writing your families and
telling them how well you're being taken
care of
and that's not all
here's page two
of that same
you could get anything
uh pencils pen holders pins
uh tobacco cigarettes five cents
that's why
80 cents a day is a lot of money or
saving up 14.80 is a lot of money when
you
pay only five cents
for a pack of cigarettes
a pipe
chewing tobacco five cents i don't know
why that someone would use it but that
there it is for five sets
um
[Music]
hair tonic anything you want
yes
yes
even in counties
that were dry
even in counties in oklahoma and gruber
oklahoma for instance
was in a dry county
but the prisoners could buy
wine and beer at the canteen
and they
officers often got wine with their
evening meals if you see this as a
concentration camp it's not
now prison is still prison and you're
still locked up
and you're bored and you're worried
about the fate of your family
you
your family is being bombed perhaps
you are living with people you may not
like
there's a lot to be said against it but
you're certainly not a concentration
camp where you are being uh badly badly
treated
yes
they could take it back they couldn't
send it back
but they could take it back and as a
matter of fact when the troops when the
germans went back uh to germany at the
end of the war as they all had to they
had duffel bags
filled with everything they could they
could uh purchase
after all they're going back to a ruined
economy and
this was
what was going to sustain them
yes why did we allow them to have the
like half with not the nazi insignia on
it wouldn't that just reinforce the nazi
ideology it would but that's what they
requested and that's what we gave them
as a matter of fact i'll show you
something in a moment
that's even more dramatic
if that's what they want just keep
telling your folks
how well you're being treated and that
they should treat ours better
um by the way the canteens uh they had
dances
uh they even had dances with local uh uh
people
uh the
the camp out here at hearn
uh
16 miles from here held uh regular
dances with girls from bryan texas
would go out and they'd had dances
we're not talking about concentration
camps
this is a uh
uh radon
all the different things you're talking
about they're getting like americanized
you know coca-cola and different things
like that effect and that was right back
home
to maybe the
demeanor of the troops that we're still
fighting like saying hey these this
american culture is not so bad you know
this you know maybe we have it wrong was
there anything like that that would go
on i'm sure there was i'm sure there was
there's no way for me to know what they
wrote back
but um
even if they wrote back saying that we
just had
uh
beer this evening
uh that was enough to tell their
families that things were going well
as opposed to
as opposed to what if those prisoners
had been captured by the russians on the
other side
they're
they were often doomed
they are being treated extremely well
here and we want their families to know
it and to treat our prisoners well
as i said it didn't work out that way
they didn't often treat our prisoners
that well if you remember movies like
stalag17 and movies about american
prisoners in in german hands
we were often starved and we were often
treated badly
yes they did it's a good question
because they did in fact
as best we can tell
there's a book coming out
um by a woman named professor barbara
heisman
uh
about the german prisoners who came back
at the end of the war
now they had to go back and they all did
but once they got there they started
scrambling to come back the economy was
in ruins
and
they tried to come back as quickly as
they could as best anyone can tell
about 5 000 we
did come back
perhaps more but they don't have to
answer that on the forums when they come
in were you a prisoner of war here
so we don't really know
but there are uh
um
german prisoners from time to time i
bumped into a man in conroe
about three months ago
had been a german prisoner here
they came back as quickly as they could
this is a
a picture of a camp this again is in
hearn and
this little castle is still there if you
happen to go out and and explore that
that
campsite
that little castle is still out there
if we're going to take nazism away from
them let's give them something else
not only democracy but religion
so
we will
we send out a call to anybody who's got
a german language bible german language
religious tracts pamphlets anything like
that
and we distributed those to the uh
to the germans we held
uh church services on sundays
for either lutherans or catholics
to try to replace the nazism we were
taking away
and then there were classes
many of the soldiers had been teachers
beforehand or they were simply experts
in something
and they offered classes many of the
classes many of the prison camps
uh offered classes that would have done
justice to a uh
to a nice uh medium-sized high school
here they are learning about american
geography the ulterior motive is
if you try to escape look how big the
country is
it's not as small as germany this is
huge
here we're teaching them english
and english is a difficult language to
learn my parents you know were
immigrants and
i saw how difficult it is to learn
my father always said never make fun of
somebody with an accent because that
means that they speak one language more
than you do
we taught them about voting most of them
never voted before
or if they did it wasn't a legitimate
election
and we gave them certificates
here's a certificate
my friend heinrich bosman
told me that he had no idea how long the
war was going to last he intended to use
the time as well as he could make
himself as
to better himself as best he could
so he took
courses in english
he took courses in he took a course in
geography
he took a course in american history
look at this
he took a course in american civics
government
here's werner richter again who had a
diploma as a as a translator by the way
when they went back to germany with
these certificates the german government
honored those certificates for
university credit
many of the of the
people who graduated from the
universities in germany graduated with
the use of these certificates they were
given credit for those certificates
if they couldn't find courses that they
liked in the camps
they were they could take
correspondence courses
they could take correspondence courses
through texas a m
through baylor
through texas tech
you could just take a correspondence
courses
there are people who graduated from
those schools who got their uh education
while they were prisoners of war
that you talked about sometimes they
would try to escape or they escaped the
light like oh that's coming yet oh
okay it's coming okay i'll get back
there
this is a wonderful picture look at this
this is aliceville alabama
two
officers
lounging now prison is still prison but
they were lounging
they had a little garden
many times the officers would have a an
armadillo on a leash that they caught
prison is still prison and i don't want
to make it attractive
but they um i've interviewed these men
by the bunch and every single one of
them told me it was the greatest time of
their lives
except for some of them
this uh cartoon appeared in the
newspapers
breaking up your crowds ain't you got
nothing better to do than stand around
planning the next war
that in every camp there was a a group
of
recalcitrant hardened nazis and they
were not going to change
it was our mistake at the very beginning
we didn't separate the nazis from the
anti-nazis
if one can do that
so we threw them all together and now we
have nazis and anti-nazis in the same
camp
the nazis uh in the camps would often
pressure the anti-nazis
they often held kangaroo courts
they would
beat one of them up
they broke into a
into the barracks and with a with a bar
of soap in a sock would beat that person
senseless
if they showed too much interest in
in the united states
as a matter of fact in hern
the camp i've mentioned before
a prisoner was murdered
it wasn't that uncommon it happened from
time to time that the nazi prisoners
would murder an anti-nazi
so there were those in the camps
uh who
were nazis and you had to be careful
about
what
kangaroo court is an unofficial court is
just where a tribunal a military
tribunal
yes
oh all right
you have a question all right
well i'm just going to hand this to you
um what would happen to the hard nazis
like you mentioned the camp and hearn
the prisoner was murdered what would
happen to the people that murdered him
because i i think wasn't the story that
he got beat with a
piece of wood that had nails in it or
something
but what would happen to the people that
killed him like anything usually nothing
if we could find them if we could find
the question is about
what happened to the people who did
these things
and generally
nothing if somebody turned them in at
the risk of their own lives
they could be
prosecuted and um some of them were from
time to time as a matter of fact a
number were even sentenced to death
uh and they were taken to leavenworth
and they were held there until the very
end of the war the moment the war was
over
they were hanged
we didn't want to hang them during the
war because they might start hanging
ours so we waited till the very last
moment
leon jaworski from houston
a famous lawyer was one of those that
that
[Music]
helped convict some of these german
prisoners but
usually not much
here is a uh
um
a funeral
in bastrop camp bastrop
uh and you'll notice that there's a nazi
flag on the on the uh coffin
uh
where would they get a nazi flag
and the answer is they asked for it
and we hope that if our prisoners asked
for an american flag that they would
give them an american flag
here's another
funeral this one in huntsville
again with a nazi fight where would they
get it they asked for it
once a month we had to sweep through the
camps
to see what they were collecting
and
that they were collecting
girly mags and things like that
that's fine they were collecting uh
patches military patches that they would
trade with the guards fine but they were
collecting tools and that's not good
that indicates that there's a an escape
being planned someplace
yeah like are they still there now or do
they the one in huntsville is the
cemetery in huntsville is not there
those prisoners those bodies were taken
back to germany
but the one in bastrop which is where
this took place
um
i don't know
i don't know if he's still there
i suspect that they were taken back to
germany
if you were a family member uh in
germany and you had a relative who died
in
in texas
and you didn't have to pay for it
perhaps they would
you'd probably ask for that body bag
they escaped like bunnies
they're 18 19 years old they're well fed
and if they weren't tired or distracted
in some way they escaped
this is the biggest escape in the
country
this was at papago park arizona where
the phoenix arizona zoo is today
if you go to phoenix arizona where the
zoo is located used to be the german
prison camp
and they
these are all navy men
they dug a very sophisticated tunnel
with lighting and air being blown in
with bellows
uh very sophisticated
a small group went out first
they went across the border into mexico
they surrendered
they were taken back to the camp and the
next time they now they knew where to
cross the border how to do it and they
took this whole group out the second
time
i was giving this talk
to a navy group in kiel germany
at the kennedy house in kiel germany
and i said
and in this major escape
five submarine captains
uh escaped the first time and in the
dark a voice said there was six of us
and it turned out he came up afterwards
and showed me his papers and showed me
an article about him about himself and
he was there were six of them who went
out the first time
here is a uh a group of uh yes
dr cameron whatever happened to uh
prisoners
[Music]
they were immediately taken back to the
camp no punishment
they were heroes as soon as they got
back to the camp
and they started planning the next
escape
and the reason is because we didn't want
our prisoners to be punished keep that
in mind that's the whole key to the
program
is
we are not going to do anything there
that's going to jeopardize our prisoners
over there
so
if they were caught and they were caught
all the time
they were picked up around here
[Music]
prisoners were
used to pole vault over the fences they
used to burrow under the fences they
used to hang underneath laundry trucks
going in and out of the camps they uh
there was a german officer i mentioned
to you once before marching up highway
79 to franklin singing german marching
songs there used to be a rexall
drugstore in
downtown o'brien
and
every now and again about once every two
or three weeks several german prisoners
will be sitting there at the counter pw
drinking a cup of coffee
somebody would ask them aren't you
fellas supposed to be out of the camp
well i guess no
and the
police would come where the sheriff
would come and put them in the truck
we're done
it just seems kind of funny if the one
in hearn i mean do you think they would
have been aware that there's a
universe or a college not far down the
road that's a you know military college
so what would happen if they showed up
walk in that direction and run into a
bunch of boys that are getting ready to
go to war in the first place
i can't imagine i don't know i don't
think that there were that many
dangerous people left on the campus
uh all our
uh all the
fellows in the corps
would have already signed up and they're
in the military
i don't think that that was a major
concern they were much more concerned
about the police
than they were about
our rotc students
it just seems like if you're in
an area where there's actual fighting
going on like say if they're over in
europe and you're in a p.o.w campus say
american or german you're american and
you're trying to escape you're trying to
head back to your home base like
where would you go in america that's a
big that's the question that
ultimately uh stopped them
was
what are we gonna do that's why we
taught them about american geography
there's no place to go
they were picked up by boy scout groups
that were out on overnight hikes
most of the prisoners
very few of them stayed out more than
three days
their english was poor
uh they were hungry
they they were mosquito bitten uh many
times they would simply come back to the
camp and and
knock on the gate and ask to be let back
in
[Music]
there was no place to go and they were
bitten up
yes um back to the
arizona
scene yeah they ever change outfits or
anything or they always have doubt
they always had pw
the reason that they had pw on their
uniforms was because
if you took a a shirt or something off a
laundry line and covered up that pw now
you could be accused of being a spy
and spies are shot
as long as you have pw written on your
on your uniform
you may be out for a shorter time but
you're not going to be shot as a spy
you're announcing i am a prisoner and
escaped prisoner of war
yes
do we know of any prisoners that escaped
that may have committed crimes
even at some murder or that
nothing that we know about
uh there no the answer is no we
we have nothing that indicates that they
did anything at all all they wanted to
do was get out get out from behind the
wire walk around in the woods meet girls
have a cup of coffee at at
rexall drugstore
there isn't any indication that they did
anything while they were out
the the uh
here are four prisoners who were picked
up by oklahoma's finest
if there's any curious about this look
how young they are
we always believe that wars are fought
by by old people like me they're not
they're fought by young kids
uh they were often caught on the buses
take you away from the area as soon as
you could
and the problem is
that they would get on the bus scamper
to the back of the bus as quickly as
they could they sat down in the back to
lay low and often they sat under the
sign that said colored only
and they didn't understand it any more
than we can understand it today
the jim crow laws
colored only
somebody would nudge somebody else and
they'd go up to the driver tell him that
there's somebody sitting in the back
the driver would stop the bus go back
there
talk to the the uh person find out that
he was an escaped german prisoner and
usually the bus driver would take the
bus back to the camp
drop the prisoner off
into the hands of the guards and then
continue on
or they
the german came on with or the escaped
prisoner came in with um
boots
leather was in very short supply during
the second world war all the leather was
going to the troops overseas and here
you got a fellow who gets on the on the
bus with big leather boots people are
nudging each other look at the boots
until the driver went back asked him
what's he
who is he and then they would
take him back to the camp
uh these are some of the things that
murdot asked about uh how do they
how do they expect to get out of here
this was taken off this comes from the
fbi files this was taken off a german
prisoner
and he expected this to get him back to
germany somehow he had a piece of paper
and access to a typewriter
the frederick chancellor employed my
hotel tree
he's a good and honest man
carolina spelled with a k hello
and this was going to get him back to
germany
he was only out a day and a half they
caught him and that was that
here's one that's a little more
sophisticated
they've found a piece of stationary u.s
army stationary they copied the seal
down here
um
and it's uh
signed by the bureau of foreigner we
don't have a bureau of foreigner
but this was
um
hopefully going to get him back to
germany
none of them
did here's another fellow who was eluded
the
the police
this is a curious thing
this was a secret program
to re-educate some germans for later use
once the war was over
we realized that once the war was over
we're going to have to run germany how
are we going to do that who's going to
run the electricity electricity the gas
the water all the things that need to be
done
we need the germans to do that
so we created and this was strictly
illegal
uh it's illegal for us to do it's
illegal for them to do to us
the the uh we went through the prison
camps found people who were anti-nazi
and we thought reliable
we sent them to uh uh for fort getty
rhode island fort eustis and we had a
secret re-education program
to
train them to be
good americans and then we shipped them
back to germany where they did exactly
what we wanted them to do
they took care of the the government
they took care of the
the electricity and the
everything we needed done
uh these were all
legitimate
what
democrats
the war is coming to an end
look what they've got they're down
they're down to the bottom look at the
fellas that they're that we're capturing
now
the war is over and now everything
starts to work in reverse
smaller camps feed into larger camps
larger camps there's still larger camps
and now everything starts to go back
toward camp shanks new york
they are
being held in new york
here they are with their duffel bags
headed for the ships
if there's anything you should know now
it is that we didn't know where to send
them
uh our
american
soldiers in germany didn't want to see
any more germans
certainly not germans who spent the last
years in the united states they never
saw how badly germany had been defeated
um
there were still nazis among them
and we um
uh the uh
general lucius clay uh in charge of the
american occupation forces said he
doesn't want to see any more uh germans
all right we can't send them back to
germany
the unions are the american unions are
screaming get these guys out of here
american soldiers shouldn't come back
from the war and find their jobs taken
by german prisoners
so the unions want them out
the the american occupation forces don't
want them there
the farmers want to keep them longer to
bring in their crops
we have a tug of war from the end of the
war 1945
on into
what are we going to do with these
prisoners the new president of the
united states president since franklin
roosevelt died in april of 1945
uh harry truman
cut the gordian knot and said he doesn't
care where they go just get them out of
here
why don't we send them to our allies
and so we have three allies to choose
from either send them to britain or send
them to france or send them to russia
the
none of them wanted to go to russia and
we felt that that might be a real
problem so we sent them to britain and
france
and that by the way becomes a very
uh sad story
the british and the french
despised these people they had been in
two world wars against the germans and
when the germans came in they treated
them very badly
they had them clearing minds dangerous
things they had them working down in the
mines also dangerous
i've interviewed these these fellows
uh and they all tell me that they lost
weight under the french or under the
british they were beaten up regularly
uh it isn't until 1947
now this is two years after the end of
the war
that the
germans are now finally returned to
germany
back on board ship
and they are sent to a number of
discharge centers in germany
where they are
given
40 marks which is four dollars
american
and a certificate saying they have
completed their prisoner war
program
and they were taken by train to their
their home towns
and as far as the prisoners are
concerned
that's the end of their story
there's a commemoration every november
in camp in fort mcclellan georgia
where the germans and the americans get
together and shake hands and so on
and there are lots of things left by the
germans
here are
german
statues built by the
germans
this in aliceville
here's something that was picked up in a
in a
flea market
done by the german prisoners you can
tell africa spelled with a k
it was done by the german prisoners if
you happen to see these things
at a flea market buy it
because they're they're
quite scarce
here is a
little cigarette case made by the german
prisoners
and on the bottom it says africa corps
prisoner of war camp camp wheeler 1944
if you would like to touch history
uh here it is
come up afterwards and see
this is
made by the german prisoners
murals are painted in lots of camps this
is outside of nazareth
in the panhandle
this i found in gruber oklahoma
at the american legion hall
here's something that was bought in a
flea market
carved out a bone pw
it's a letter opener and a pen
this was in gruber oklahoma
it says germany holy fatherland
deutschland heiligsfaterlund
right there in a small little park i
walked over to that little house on the
side and i said you know what those
that's what that thing is
oh
i said the german prisoners were here
[Music]
so what i'm saying is you can still find
these things
left by the german prisoners
here's a canteen
hern texas prisoner of war
camp here's another mural
they have reunions
they have prisoner of war reunions
they come back with with big beer
bellies and grandchildren and they and
they meet the guards who have big beer
bellies and grandchildren and they hug
one another and they talk about the old
days and they talk about how they played
pranks on the guards and how they used
to make
wine as the prisoners often did taking
the the raisins out of the raisin toast
in the morning putting it in a mason jar
filled with sugar and water covered with
muslin cloth leave it out in the
sunshine every boy scout knows how to do
this
leave it out in the
sun and about eight hours later that
stuff will knock you down
they come back and they have reunions
here's another reunion
all the prisoners had to go back
at the end of the war
at first we
couldn't account for about 300 and then
slowly we began to pick them up
until there were only 12. there were 12
prisoners left outstanding
one was picked up in by the fbi in 1947
49 52
a fellow named reinhold pavel
had opened a bookstore in chicago
married an american girl opened a
bookstore in chicago even had the the
joy of selling books to former guards
from camp grant
outside of chicago where he escaped from
they picked them up 57 58 59
and in 1980
the last prisoner of war uh
george uh
uh it doesn't matter anyway um
was declared dead tell me
i'm just wondering where you got the
cigarette box oh this was given to me by
somebody who found it in a flea market
only one prisoner left outstanding
and this is him
um
his name is george gertner georg gertner
he
escaped from deming new mexico
jumped a train went to california
lived out his
most of his life in california
married an american girl
had two children
he picked crops up and down the imperial
valley
um he moved to hawaii for a short time
george gertner
here he is on his way to north africa
with the africa corps
and here's his escape
his wanted poster
and in 1984 he called me on the
telephone
are you the fellow who wrote that book
about the prisoners of war yes
he said i love that book oh that's great
it's just terrific i said well what did
you like about it there's no such thing
as too much praise i said what did you
like about it he said it was so accurate
i loved it it was just so accurate i
said well you must have been one of
those prisoners
you must have been one of those
prisoners if you know how accurate it
was
well yes i was a german prisoner and
there's still plenty of them around
and he started telling me the same the
stories about how they used to make wine
play pranks on the guards and uh and
things like that
um
and then he stopped for a while and he
said this is i said i've got an early
class tomorrow i'm a teacher and i
haven't got that i can't talk any longer
and he said wait a minute this is really
important to me
i said why is that and the phone went
dead for about 15 seconds which is a
long time
uh and finally in a very s
quiet voice he said i'm the last german
prisoner
i said well hello mr gartner how are you
everybody knows there's only one left
and this is him he got frightened he
hung up
and then he called me back about two
weeks later
and we eventually made a plan to meet at
the westin hotel in houston
and i
let's see if i've got it
this is
he became a tennis pro
in california took on the name of dennis
wiles w-h-i-l-e-s
people in the tennis business say that
he was a good name dennis wiles
he used to play with bjorn borg
world champion
he played with robert stack
with lloyd bridges
ball bridge is his father for those of
you who aren't
um
oh look at that black hair oh my god
that's you
oh please please
inside of every old person there once
was a young person
and here i am in the western hotel
taping his uh
story
and
his wife is sitting just about where i'm
standing now sitting on the bed with her
fingers in her mouth she had no idea
that he was german
he told her that he came from upstate
new york and she figured that everybody
from upstate new york talks like this
and he told her his parents died in a
crash that he went to the boys school
blah and she sat there with her fingers
in her mouth dennis you mean we have
relatives in germany yes dear dennis you
mean you were in the africa core yes
dear dennis and she sat there listening
to uh as i taped his story
i wrote a book about it called hitler's
last soldier in america
i don't know if i brought i did
hitler's last soldier in america
um
and uh
it came out in
85 6 something like that and it was oh
it was all over
a m professor oh look at that dark hair
i can't believe it
this is humiliating look at that
dark hair
anyway hitler's last soldier surrendered
it was it was a big thing yes i'm sorry
matthew
uh my question was
with the care that the german soldiers
and probably all the action forces were
doing with the us they're all riding
home
their families telling them how good it
was
is there ever any
fear from the
access command that towards the end of
the war some of their soldiers might
kind of just throw down their guns and
you know walk walk into the hands of the
american forces of the alligators yeah
they did
you know that's true for one of these
camps yeah it was true and they did
german soldiers were near the end of the
war german soldiers were surrendering to
us
by in holy units they were surrendering
to us in in by the battalion sometimes
so many in fact that we told them they
had to bring their own food in their own
field kitchens
because we couldn't feed them
there were so many germans surrendering
to us and largely because of the
propaganda that we were having those it
wasn't even propaganda with stuff that
we were sending the uh
the germans yeah and with the russians
on the as the other alternative
they wanted to come to us
at the end let me tell you
i checked to find that they ran a survey
at the very end and they found that 74
percent of the prisoners who were
returned to germany at the end of the
war
were leaving with a high appreciation
for democracy in the united states
and about 15 percent left with
unfavorable attitude toward the united
states
so did that work out for us
74 percent were were had a very high
appreciation of america and 15 percent
left with an unfavorable attitude
and they weren't going to change
here's
this was at the checkout counter and
i feared my hubby was a murderer
the german pow came in from the coal
this was everywhere
um
he became an american citizen
got his passport now he could leave the
united states if he needed if he wanted
to and he did he wanted to go back to
germany they were holding twelve
thousand dollars for him uh this was his
military pay that had been accumulating
all these years he got up he got uh
twelve thousand dollars he was a hero
in germany for several months
uh he stayed an additional six months
uh his wife was getting very annoyed
and while he was gone she divorced him
she was just tired of being lied to two
children and she didn't know who he was
[Music]
and sadly
he died
three weeks ago
four weeks ago
gareth gartner his toad
is dead
well what questions have you about the
german prisoners of war
noah
um is it true that german prisoners
tried to volunteer to fight the japanese
in the us
i am so tempted
[Laughter]
the question is
did the german prisoners try to organize
a german volunteer corps
to fight the japanese on our behalf and
the answer is yes
they
there was an organization in almost
every camp
they were trying to
get out of the camp first of all
they were also modeling themselves after
the japanese nissai who were
rounded up on the west coast
and they were encouraged to join an
american unit called the 442nd
infantry division
the gopher broke division
to fight the germans and they thought
maybe we as prisoners can fight the
japanese and that went all the way to
the top it all it went all the way to
the top of the provost marshal general's
office
should we do this or not here we have an
uh we can create a large unit maybe even
a whole division
uh to help us fight the japanese with
whom we were still at war
and uh they
discarded the idea and the reason they
discarded that noah was because
if they came into the to help us fight
we had to make them u.s soldiers and if
we had to make them u.s soldiers now
they became eligible for the gi bill of
rights
more than that
we would have to
give them all the courtesies all the
things that the that the american
soldiers got
and including a salary and that we just
decided not to do
well that's a good question
tell me
um where did all the money come from to
pay for the camps
uh most of it was self-sustaining most
of it came from the farmers who paid in
the farmers paid cash to the government
and the government gave the prisoners
coupons
so there's a lot of money going into the
government and the government's paying
people with coupons
um
[Music]
much it was self-sustaining
i think that there were also
communities got together and produced
all the religious stuff
and the musical instruments
um
that's a good question because i just
feel like it would take a lot of
like building materials just to
physically create these camps yeah like
not just the food and the entertainment
and
resources like
that building material that's a good
idea it's a good question
i don't know i'll look it up
or don
the officer you shove the picture up
that was in the play or dressed like a
woman yes how did he rise up so far
uh
and he said he was uh an ambassador
he was president of the united states
how did he get that far being you know a
nazi soldier german soldier like
wouldn't that have had like a kind of a
black mark on it was an aristocrat
i don't know exactly how i'm sure he was
a brilliant man
um
i'm sure he was a brilliant man i don't
know
it didn't hold him back
not in a country that was
one-third
members of the party
yes okay so some of the pows were housed
in gems what did those high schools or
schools do
did was the school to shut down or did
they kevin that i just i can only
imagine that they that the gym was off
limits to everybody
yeah but if the government says we need
your gym and it's wartime
you'll allow them to sure
tell me
um
i think that it's nothing else they
certainly formed the military
units organizations
not the old clubs the bowling clubs and
things like that but i think they formed
i know they formed uh military
organizations they still have reunions
in germany
i've been to uh
uh some of the reunions africa corps
reunions they have all over germany
the
ss has reunions
they have newsletters that come out
about once every month i've got some in
my office if you're interested
africa core newsletters
that come out every month
they're still
on the ss
they're still holding hands in the dark
but whether they form the old
organizations the bowling and things
like that i don't think so
yes
how did the government get the community
to be
um i guess so nice to the german pows
like
today if we have pows come most of the
community is going to be hostile towards
them i would imagine whereas like bus
drivers would pick them up and return
them on the bus to the prison camps
why wasn't there much hostility towards
the german people well at the beginning
there was
most of the time they were
startled here at hearn for instance
the whole town turned out on both sides
of the roads as the africa corps were
marched out to their camp
singing uh marching songs and the
population was was
bewildered these first of all
most people hadn't seen the grown men in
some time all our boys were overseas
fighting
here are
very healthy
tan
soldiers
they didn't like them at the beginning
one of the things that as a matter of
fact they caught they used to refer to
the prison camps not just here but
almost everywhere as the fritz ritz
that they were in such good i mean they
could drink wine and beer with their
evening meals officers
in communities that were dry
and the reason they could do that is
because they were governed by federal
law and federal law supersedes local law
so if local law says that it's a it's a
dry county
federal law supersedes that and they can
have wine and beer
with their evening meals
there were lots of camps around the
country
the total number of camps the big camps
were 155
there were about 500 camps total
small ones enlarged together
there were three layers of camps in the
united states
there was one layer for the japanese
nissai from california
and that was under the war relocation
plan war relocation administration
taking 120 000 japanese americans most
of whom had been born in the united st
camps on the west coast
there was a second layer of camps the
prisoner of war camps
there was a third layer of camps for
enemy aliens
german citizens who were somehow suspect
uh who were uh
turned in by somebody
and picked up by the fbi they were
called enemy aliens
and there was an enemy alien camp
in almost every major
city
the biggest camp around here was crystal
city on the other side of u-valley 24
000 people were held out there
generally german
german citizens never learned english
they never got their citizenship
and we were at war with germany so it
seems prudent at the time if somebody
turned you in
to
go see what you're up to
this was a very intolerant country
during the war
while we're overseas fighting for truth
and justice and freedom
we were
a bit intolerant at home
yes
well
it depends on the community
there was very little contact between
the germans and places like new
braunfels and fredericksburg those
people had learned in world war one keep
your head down
don't get involved keep your head down
there weren't that many uh
there wasn't much traffic between
americans and the germans
near the end of the war there was as a
matter of fact there were
[Music]
occasions where the german prisoners
were dating
american
girls um my friend heinrich bozeman who
collected all these certificates
uh told me that he had four girlfriends
while he was
uh in florida he had four girlfriends
and he told me that the addresses
at the same time
i didn't pry
i didn't pry but whatever it was
uh he had four girlfriends
anything else about the prisoners this
is really a part of the second world war
that we don't know anything about and it
took place here
they brought in the crops they had a
huge impact on the farming families
around here around any place
there's a famous story about a
farmer who
died in kansas
and he died without any family or any
children and he left his farm to the
german prisoner who worked on the farm
for him during the war
farmers often sent care packages to the
germans to keep them
alive in germany after the war
[Music]
and it had a huge impact on the germans
those people went back
and and
prospered
they've run studies on how many of those
people climbed the ladder of success
with all these certificates speaking
english
they did much better
than the average german
what else strikes you
anything
well if not it's not
come on
okay obviously
all of the able-bodied men of younger
age were fighting the war so when the
president the prisoners came in were
there any instances of
marriages breaking up because
the husband was overseas and the wife
was here and she fell in love with it oh
i don't know i don't know that's
i don't know that's
tell us yes she wants to hear yes
oh my god
there was just it was just uh i can't
even tell you what was what was going on
yes
during the health and comfort inspection
obviously they had contraband as
prisoner of wars and i was just
wondering if they were liable
individually the convention for having
contraband and if they were applicable
to the ucmj due to the fact that they
were under military
i think that the
they were given a pass the first couple
of times
but if he continued then they were
thrown in the brig
yeah
the thing is that when you punish them
too hard they'll just find some way to
go underground they'll bury that stuff
they'll do something with it that that
it can't be picked up
so um
they were under military control you're
exactly right
and i think the first several times all
we did was confiscated
and uh
i think if it kept up we would we we
went after them
but we wanted to be careful because as
always what we do to them here we felt
they were due to ours
what else
anything
no going once
going twice
yes
crystal
oh just under the wire crystal
did the fact that our thought process
didn't work out since american troops
weren't treated so well overseas changed
the way that we now treat pows
oh that's a good question
i wonder i don't know but i wonder
whether or not crystal's asking did the
the fact that it didn't work out quite
the way we hoped
uh could that influence how we are
treating our prisoners of war today in
guantanamo guantanamo and places like
that
i don't know i wonder it's a different
kind of it's a different era it's
different wars this is a
non-symmetrical
war
there are no passports there are no
uniforms there are no
um
i i don't know i wonder if we are
my impulse is to say no they're not
classified
no you're right
this is uh we're decent people i think
we would have done the same thing anyway
that's a good question
anything else
no
everybody's happy
all right
[Applause]
join us each saturday at 8 p.m and
midnight eastern and sundays at 1pm for
classroom lectures from across the
country on different topics and eras of
american history
lectures in history are also available
as podcasts
visit our website at cspan.org
history slash podcasts or download them
from itunes
it's not
i think inaccurate to suggest that had
we had public opinion polls